right behind me here is a newly planted
bed of habanero peppers but just a few
days ago it was a cover crop of winter
ride and in this video I'm going to show
you how to use wintery cover crops as a
sheet mulch in a no tail Garden the
winter Rye crop behind me was uh planted
in like mid September the date today is
April 30th it's very important that
before you actually crimp the winter
ride that it has these flower heads on
it we want to crimp it before it forms a
viable seed but it's still ready to die
and that's how the plant will die easily
by crimping and tarping otherwise the
plant's just going to want to Spring
right back up and it's going to be hard
to terminate basically so it grew all
winter with no irrigation right next to
this High tunnel and the reason I put it
there is for erosion control basically
and to kind of make the soil better in
that area too that bed's just never
really performed really great and then
the water rushes off that high tunnel
and kind of washes off these beds
because the whole Garden's on an incline
this way and all my other beds go in
this direction except for this High
tunnel and these beds so the water
usually rushes down the hill this way
which works good in most of my garden
but in this part of the garden it kind
of causes problems wash out and so my
thought is that I put a pause button on
it for the winter help with erosion
control keep the soil in place while at
the same time bringing nutrients up from
way deep down within the soil and then
how I'm going to crimp this helps build
the soil up help with like wash out and
stuff that I'm going to have so to crimp
it this is just like a standard toost
right nothing fancy it costs no money so
this is just a leftover rope from when I
bought the caterpillar tunnels I've got
four green houses and they come with
this rope to help hold the plastic down
and there's always extra so it's great
for little projects around the farm
things like that so I'm literally just
cutting off like an arms length of this
rope and and then I'm going to tie it
around my toot
so got two lengths they're not quite
exactly the same size but doesn't really
matter I'm going to tie them to the
toost first so I just tie a loop in
it like
this and then that makes it so that I
can make a
loop like this just kind of lasso that
around my
TST that's it and I'm going to do
something similar on this
end and then that's it and I'm just
going to take this like
this and that's it and so now I'm just
going to take the tool I'm just going to
step on it I'm just going to crimp it
right down to the ground so the next
step is to tarp it and the wetter the
better so if you can like run your
irrigation over it first or I'm just
since it's such a small plot I'm just
going to water it with the hose but you
really want to like trap the moisture in
under the tarp and that really helps
like steam it to kill the cover crop if
I were just leave it like that it's just
going to Spring right back up and keep
growing I find that the tarping with
this method like actually is necessary
and then it can't just be like any tarp
you don't want to like go to Home Depot
and just pick up a tarp it has to be a
silage tarp and then I always make the
grass uh facing one way so then I can
bring the drag the tarp over it that way
and I'm bringing it all this way that
way the grass doesn't get caught on it
like going that way I just kind of like
piece together some tarps that I had
laying around here greenhouse plastic
left over from when I built the green
houses to kind of get this end because
it you know all my tarps are 50 ft long
for my 50t long beds but then when you
crimp the cover crop it sticks out like
several feet so if you don't cover that
somehow and get it to diee it's just
going to like curl back back up towards
the sun in my experience all right so
it's been about like 10 days I think
that I crimped the winter Rye last
Wednesday and today's Thursday so it's
been 8 days it's interesting to see like
at the other end like I put that little
piece of pla uh greenhouse plastic
instead of silage tarp and that just
turned brown like within a few days uh I
just kind of peaked under the tarp and
it's still a little bit green um it's
not completely brown but it's like kind
of Rotty smelling you know like it's
dead it's not coming back um so I'd like
to wait like another I'd love to leave
the tarp there for another week but the
truth is I got to go do deliveries all
day tomorrow I got two workers that are
going to be here they need something to
do I got pepper plants that are This
Tall that I need to get planted so I
just need to get plants in the ground
get these beds making me money keep my
workers busy so I'm just going to get
this bed prepped and ready for them um
so I'm going to pull the tarps back and
we'll see what it looks like there you
go you can see that's what it looks like
after about 8 days you can see it's all
facing the same direction it's like
straw it's like mulching your garden
with straw only it was grown there and
the roots are still in the ground and
then so I thought it was really
interesting like on this end you can see
how it's just like brown brown dead so I
had a little extra scrap piece of
greenhouse plastic that I put right here
and that's the difference of like
solarizing it or using the silage tarp
so if you got a piece of greenhouse
plastic I mean you I mean it looked like
that after 2 days so you could
essentially tarp this with greenhouse
plastic for 2 days be done build your
beds and plant something else there was
a bed of arugula right next to it and
then it just so happened that we
harvested that bed of arugula the same
day as we crimped this cover crop so we
harvested the arugula crimp the cover
crop and then just tarped both beds to
terminate both beds so now both beds are
ready to be replanted so I'm just going
to like measure out my beds I I use
states with strings attached and I
measure out the bed so I can keep
straight lines and I'm going to freshen
up all the wood chips along the side of
the tunnel right here put fresh compost
right on top of this winter rye and then
fresh compost on top of this uh
terminated arugula bed and we're going
to plant peppers in both of these beds
I'm pretty sure I'm going to go ahead
get them measured out and get the beds
rebuilt I just kind of like keep a few
of these buckets around and so I just
grab the bucket you know it's got like a
hammer in it tape
measure and uh a bunch of these
things just with string on them so I can
string the beds up measure them out and
keep everything nice and
straight there's a few weeds I'm going
to go and H them out you always want to
take care of any Weeds now you know you
don't want to ignore the weeds that are
right here on the sides that you miss
cuz those are just going to become big
weeds drop seeds and then you're just
going to have more weeds you want to
take care of that stuff now and then you
don't have to come back and weed this
Garden ever the winter ride not only
acts as a mulch but it's got an alop
theic effect so it mulches the soil and
then it inhibits weed seeds that might
be in the soil from germinating for
several weeks anyway it's doesn't last
forever but now I'm going to put compost
right on top of that and then wood chips
in the walkways and you don't
necessarily have to put wood chips in
the walkways you can just use the winter
Ry as a mulch but I just find it it's
like difficult to walk on so if you're
going to walk in your walkways a lot
you're going to slip on the winter ride
but it does a great job at uh mulching
the bed and then once I put compost on
top of that like you're not going to get
any weeds for the rest of the year on
that bed okay so now that I put the
compost down I'm going to go ahead and
like rake the compost smooth on the beds
and then once that's nice and tight then
I come back in and I fill in kind of the
Gap with wood chips and it just kind of
like fills the raised bed kind of nicely
you know and like I how I showed you how
I crimp It All in One Direction on
purpose like I really messed it up by
going this way with the wheelbarrow you
can see how like by stepping on it and
walking that way with it it like I like
kicked it up so I'm going to try to fix
that the best I can
so I was out doing my deliveries today
and I had Max and Katie my workers uh
finish this in with filling it in with
wood chips so I told them that we'll
Harvest this bed of salanova lettuce
next week and then we'll uh fill in the
wood chips right there and then we'll
probably freshen up that whole big uh
little walkway right there but um so
this is what it looks like when we're
done right you can't even tell that
there's a cover crop under there so I
just built the garden right on top of
the sheet malt cover crop so I'll show
you what it looks like